she picked her up by her pigtails it did
sort of like an Olympic hammer throw
over a wrought iron fence that's an
arrest of all offense hello I'm Dan I
was an adjunct professor in art and film
and today I'm gonna be taking a look at
some famous depictions of teachers and
movies and television and telling you
what I think
1990s Kindergarten Cop a favorite of
mine back in the 90s let's see how it
holds up today we're going to play a new
fun game it's called police it's cool
what child isn't excited to play a game
in school first and foremost no more
complaining no more mr. Kemp left to go
to the bathroom nothing there is no
bathroom problematic he should
definitely allow those children to go to
the bathroom that's how you get bladder
disorders laughs got news for you you're
mine now you belong to me I've been a
child like I know what it's like to have
an authority figure tell you that your
parents can't help you like this is
you're with me now
that's downright terrifying these
children should be bursting into tears
and maybe I was just a very sensitive
child as far as what he's doing you know
he's establishing Authority I can't
begrudge that not necessarily falling in
line with a school of teaching that I
would go with he's not trying to
establish trust he's trying to rule by
fear but um I mean you expect nothing
less from the Terminator I mean come on
I would say that if I had to put him
into an A through F grade scale he's a
deed he's not passing he could bring it
up to a c-minus if he were to reverse
that bathroom policy that really stuck
with me I don't know maybe that hit
something in me but tilde oh okay she's
carrying around a riding crop this kid
just wants to please my mommy thinks
they're sweet your mommy
twick this this teacher who is caring
Retta a writing crop throughout the
entire scene and is poking the girl i
mean obviously that's a that's a
non-starter there's a real hard
zero tolerance at least for me when it
comes to striking children
[Music]
good level of discipline is something
that I wish on no child hard f for this
for this teacher and prison truthfully
beyond death expulsion true expulsion
School of Rock 2003 School of Rock I
don't want to give a bad grade to Jack
Black I really hope you hear holds up
here's the deal I've got a hangover who
knows what that means
doesn't mean your trunk no it means I
was drunk yesterday definitely falling
victim to two things I've done as a
teacher before number one he's trying to
be cool he's trying to be the cool
teacher
the second thing he's guilty of which
I've asked me guilty of is trying to
like he's wearing like a teacher costume
innocence I hope I haven't come off this
badly Jack like ultimately he passes
he's gonna get through the day he's not
going to probably strike a child he's
the type of like teacher this is gonna
throw on a film throw on like a nice
solid PG movie he's great as a c-plus is
it solid c-plus I think there's room for
improvement Breaking Bad 2008 I mean 58
I was close what is close there's no
clothes in science Barry there are right
answers and wrong answers classic
science teacher yeah but I'm just saying
mr. white two points I mean I really
studied like really really studied like
all night hard and the students not
doing a good job of convincing me that
he deserves a second chance
couldn't you please just let this slide
don't believe the answer is no next time
apply yourself yeah there's nothing
worse than when a student's like can't
you just let this slide if he's having
an issue in the classroom this is
something that could be voiced long
before a test happens I'm gonna give
Walter White a solid b-plus no you know
what take it down
b-minus he could have curbed some of the
language Boy Meets World all right so I
have never seen Boy Meets World my
savages Fred not been I cheated mr.
Feeny I had the answers to the test
written on my hand
and you only managed an a-minus why did
you do this mr. Matthews I don't know I
really wanted to go to Europe this
summer nay I don't have much centerpiece
of privilege so that's superficial miss
Matthews
perhaps it's something a little deeper
there is no deeper with me mr. Feeny I'm
not a good student might as well just
accept it
I have the only thing that limits you
mr. Matthews is your laziness I mean
you're just looking for an excuse to
never get the grades that I know you're
capable of getting I'm not capable I
don't write people off mr. Matthews
you're a good teacher mr. Feeny he is
yes a good teacher
I look forward to working with you in
some school yeah it'll be good summer
and that sitcom freeze-frame at the end
whoa he's understanding he's clearly
listening which is something that I
think a lot of teachers often don't do
he seems to really be taking the
specifics of this students situation
into account and listened and said yes I
understand but there'll be other like
Europe's not going anywhere
hopefully I mean mr. Feeny gets an A in
my book he got the student to do what he
wanted the student to do and he did it
without threats without harsh language
without bullying that takes a a certain
type of person we can all aspire to be a
mr. Feeny I'm your substitute teacher
mr. Garvey I taught school for 20 years
and I love this kept some so don't even
think about mess with me feel me let's
take roll here Jay Quellin where's Jay
Quellin net no Jay Quellin here
sorry it's do you mean Jacqueline okay
so that's how it's gonna be
y'all want to play he's coming in and
sort of the opposite of a Jack Black
he's like he knows he's coming into a
none know dynamic and he just asserts
himself as a strong authority figure if
one of y'all says some silly-ass name
this whole class is gonna feel my wrath
now dee-nice do you mean Denise I love
that sketch pronouncing someone's name
is incredibly important when you
willingly pronounce it wrong or don't
take the time to learn how to pronounce
it right you're sort of stripping them
of a level of humanity so I think it's
very important to learn how to pronounce
the student's name correctly it's also
good to establish any a space to where
they can correct you about
pronunciations about pronouns about
identification
I'll give him a c-minus he's got some
learning to do I would say honestly out
of all of these Walter White might be
the most accurate and that's a little
scary
pictures of teachers on film and
typically only deal with classroom
moments you don't see a lot of teachers
just like slinking in the corner
in the teachers lounge like eating a
sandwich and just kind of coming down
from the two hours that they spent
talking without a break I'd like to see
more of the the come down or like the
the sad teachers lounge coffee coming
you don't see a lot of a lot of that a
lot of the stress relievers that are
necessary to teach another class
[Music]